sur le président du sénat monsieur le
président de l'assemblée nationale
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les bancs du gouvernement
il y a ici à la fois les représentants
des plus hautes autorités de l'état et
aussi les représentants de ce que l'état
peut faire de mieux pour le pays
il ya
généralement une cérémonie pour le
discours au corps constitués avec un
protocole bien établi où le
vice-président du conseil d'état fait
une intervention et je lui réponds et
puis il y a aussi des voeux qui sont
adressées par le président de la
république aux assemblées
compte tenu des circonstances il a été
décidé de vous rassembler et de ne faire
qu'une seule cérémonie
parce que dix jours après les attaques
terroristes
je voulais m'adresser à vous tous
présidents des assemblées manque du
gouvernement parlementaires
représentants des différents corps de
l'état
pour vous dire d'abord notre
reconnaissance pour ce cas était l'unité
de notre pays dans le cadre de nos
institutions
pour dire aussi ma gratitude
à l'égard des fonctionnaires qui ont par
leur comportement exemplaire
montré une fois encore la force de la
république
la nation a été mise à l'épreuve
elle a même été frappée au coeur c'est à
dire dans ses principes fondamentaux
la liberté d'expression et la liberté de
conscience
elle a été frappée dans ces institutions
la police
parce qu'elle était visée en tant que
telle
a été frappé dans sa chair par le
meurtre de 17 citoyens et citoyens
français
face à cette agression notre peuple a
montré sa vitalité
il a exprimé aussi sa fierté dans les
valeurs de la république
l'esprit du 11 janvier doit désormais
inspirer notre action dans la durée
c'est exceptionnel que des millions de
français
descendent dans la rue n'ont pas peut
protester
non pas pour contester mais pour
affirmer leur attachement
à ce qui nous unit tous la république
ce qui exige de nous désormais de nous
placer à la hauteur des événements
de repousser les vaines querelles
et les polémiques inutiles
de nous unir autour des réformes
indispensables c'est à dire de celles
qui dépassent des intérêts catégoriels
par ailleurs légitime on les intérêts
partisans par ailleurs nécessaire
nos principes républicains
ont été maintes fois éprouvée dans
l'histoire et nous pouvions avoir des
doutes sur la capacité de notre pays à
pouvoir résister face aux à ce qu'était
une attaque contre son identité même et
une fois encore nos institutions nos
principes ont montré leur robustesse et
leur solidité
les déclinistes il y en a les fatalistes
les défaitistes croyait que les ressorts
de la france était brisée elle s'est
mise debout d'un bon avec la plus grande
vigueur
à nous maintenant élus et fonctionnaires
de préserver cet état d'esprit
de garantir le rassemblement qui ne fera
pas disparaître les différences et les
clivages mais qui permettra d'aller à
l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est d'abord de protéger
nos concitoyens dans le respect du droit
les lois du 21 décembre 2012 et du 13
novembre 2014 ont déjà étendu les moyens
juridiques dont nous disposons pour
surveiller et punir ceux qui fomentent
ou envisagent de participer à des
entreprises terroristes
mais des mesures supplémentaires doivent
être prises
le premier ministre y travaillent et les
présentera demain
pour contrôler les déplacements des
jihadistes pour renforcer notre système
de renseignement pour empêcher la
propagation de l'islamisme radical dans
nos prisons et pour mieux surveiller et
empêcher les agissements de cette
mouvance sur internet devront prendre
ces mesures
dans le respect des libertés parce que
c'est ce que la france a voulu aussi
signifié et se serait finalement servir
les terroristes que dans ab nos
principes que de mettre en cause les
bases mêmes qui font de nos institutions
et en même temps nous devons assurer la
sécurité faire en sorte aussi que chaque
citoyen puisse être pleinement dans la
république et que nul ne soit tenté de
s'en détourner la solution on le sait
est globale elle passe par la
mobilisation de toutes nos institutions
l'éducation
la justice la police et avec tous les
outils de l'intégration ce que
gouvernements successifs ont voulu y
mettre en place et qu'il nous convient
de faire vivre je veux faire deux
propositions
d'abord pour les jeunes je veux
développer gelé déjà annoncé massivement
le service civique tous les jeunes
volontaires doivent pouvoir se voir
offrir cette possibilité
ils sont à peine quarante mille
aujourd'hui et il y a quatre demandes
sur cinq qui restent sans réponse j'ai
donc décidé que tous les volontaires
pour le service civique pourront être
accueillis à l'horizon 2017 ce qui
représente entre 150 milles et 170 mille
personnes
mais pour tous les français de tous âges
je veux développer toutes les
possibilités d'engagement parce que
c'est dans le service de l'intérêt
général que se renforcent la citoyenneté
c'est dans cet esprit que je demande au
président du sénat et au président de
l'assemblée nationale s'il en
conviennent d'engager une mission de
réflexion sur toutes les formes
d'engagement et sur le renforcement de
l'appartenance républicain j'ai compris
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'idées qui était
aujourd'hui avant c est tant mieux elle
mérite d'être évalués c'est vrai pour le
service civique c'est également vrai
pour toutes les formes de volontariat je
pense aussi à la protection civile à la
réserve citoyenne pour nos armées au
bénévolat bref tout ce qui peut
contribuer à renouer à renforcer le lien
civique je souhaite que ces deux
autorités puissent me faire des
propositions qui s'appuieront sur des
travaux de leurs assemblées respectives
une large consultation des citoyens et
qu'ils puissent dans un délai qui doit
être de l'ordre d'un mois au plus tard
donc à la fin du mois de mars leur
proposition
le deuxième intérêt impératif c'est de
restaurer la confiance dans nos
institutions
pour y répondre la transparence
démocratique doit s'ajouter à l'
exemplarité républicaine
l'exemplarité passe d'abord par une
évidence c'est à dire la probité de ce
qui représente la puissance publique à
tous les niveaux trop longtemps notre
pays s'est contenté d'affirmer des
grands principes sans se donner les
moyens de leur respect la france s'est
dotée d'une nouvelle législation sur la
transparence de la vie publique et en
2004 la haute autorité pour la
transparence a largement fait la preuve
de son utilité et de son efficacité en à
peine un an d'existence
20000 déclaration
9000 responsables publics qui ont été
amenés à donner l'état de leur
patrimoine
élu comme haut fonctionnaire
et plusieurs centaines qui ont été
rendus publics
fort de ce bilan jean louis nadal le
président de la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique a fait
des propositions
pour encore améliorer notre
réglementation j'en retiens plusieurs
tout d'abord pour éviter que des
manquements ne soient connus
postérieurement à l'entrée en fonction
des intéressés il devra être procédé à
des vérifications avant tout les
nominations des plus importantes je sais
aussi que les assemblées travaille sur
des propositions par rapport aux
candidatures aux élections
ensuite les nouvelles règles
déontologiques seront étendues à tous
les acteurs publics
fonctionnaires comme magistrat des
projets de loi seront déposées au
parlement et seront bientôt inscrit à
l'ordre du jour enfin il faudra encore
rendre plus claires là que vous
confection des lois et des règlements
pour un meilleur encadrement des groupes
de pression c'est un chantier qui a été
ouvert cette année et les citoyens
seront désormais qui est intervenu à
quel niveau auprès des décideurs publics
pour améliorer
corrigé modifier une réforme et quels
ont été les arguments utilisés
pour aller aussi loin que possible dans
cette exemplarité et dans cette
transparence le premier sera demandé à
michel sapin de préparer un projet de
loi pour aussi évoqué la transparence
dans la vie économique
l'exemplarité suppose aussi une justice
indépendante depuis 2012 j'ai toujours
veillé à ce que jamais l'exécutif
n'interfère dans les dossiers de la
justice pas plus que dans son
fonctionnement et notamment à travers
les nominations de procureurs c'est la
garantie d'une relation confiante et
apaisées entre l'exécutif et l'autorité
judiciaire
j'exprime de nouveau le souhait que la
garde des sceaux puisse reprendre le
projet de loi constitutionnelle pour
donner de nouveaux pouvoirs en conseil
supérieur de la magistrature pour la
nomination des juges du parquet c'est un
texte qui devrait réunir une large
majorité de parlementaires et qui nous
mettrait à l'abri de certaines décisions
venant de la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme
parce que notre parquet ne serait pas
indépendant
il s'agit aussi de donner une base
juridique solide à des pratiques qui
sont déjà les nôtres le ministère public
en sera renforcée et le statut de tous
les magistrats gary fier
une justice exemplaire c'est une justice
accessible à tous c'est le sens du
projet pour la justice du xxème siècle
que porte la garde des sceaux la justice
du quotidien c'est le fonctionnement
simple et rapide des prud'hommes des
tribunaux de commerce des contentieux
civil mais aussi économiques et sociaux
c'est tout ce qui touche à la vie des
entreprises et des particuliers
cette réforme se déploie à travers
plusieurs textes dont le premier est
déjà en discussion puisque il s'agit du
projet de loi croissance et activités
qui assouplit les conditions d'accès aux
professions du droit et qui réforme la
justice prud'homale
l'idée aussi c'est que les juridictions
civiles de première instance puisse voir
leurs procédures et leur organisation
simplifiée à travers le regroupement
dans un pôle social
unifié du contentieux de l'aide sociale
du handicap de la sécurité sociale
la justice commerciale devra également
être réformé et nous devrons pas où
c'est possible développer les procédures
de conciliation de médiation pour
permettre d issue plus rapide et plus
lisible pour nos concitoyens
l'exemplarité c'est enfin des lois bien
écrite et rapidement mises en oeuvre
et là je pense que c'est une
responsabilité collective c'est pourquoi
il était utile de vous rassembler tous'
non seulement les lois sont longues mais
elles sont complexes
mais elles ne sont pas appliquées dans
le délai qui convient les parlementaires
peuvent passer des nuits
et des jours entiers allait voter avec
le des procédures pour accélérer encore
les délibérations mais si les décrets
d'application ne sont pas pris en temps
et en heure
à quoi sert cette célérité
en 2014 à peine 60% des textes
d'application des lois ont été publiées
et notamment dans un domaine essentiel
qu'est le logement est donc le premier
ministre a demandé aux membres du
gouvernement
de procéder à la revue de tous les
décrets restant à sortir dans leur
propre département ministériel et à
veiller à leur publication rapide mieux
légiférer c'est aussi mieux préparer les
projets de loi c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle j'ai décidé de rompre avec
une tradition séculaire des secrets qui
entourent les avis du conseil d'état
le conseil d'état et le conseil
juridique du gouvernement et son avis
est d'intérêt public
et donc son expertise sera rendue
publique
le conseil d'état donc par ses avis
informera les citoyens mais éclairera
aussi les débats parlementaires
mieux légiférer
c'est mieux travailler avec le parlement
en l'associant plus en amont
pour pouvoir accélérer accélérer si
nécessaire la procédure
en faisant en sorte que les études
d'impact puisse évaluer la réforme au
moment du débat et non à la suite est
d'associer les parlementaires à la mise
en oeuvre des textes qu'ils auront voté
ou pas voter
le dernier impératif
c'est de redonner confiance
dans l'avenir
et le gouvernement doit dans cette
période à tous égards exceptionnelle
parce que les français aussi non voulues
exceptionnel le gouvernement doit
poursuivre avec ardeur et audace sa
tâche réformatrice pour moderniser le
pays et notamment les services publics
il s'agit pas de réformer pour réformer
ou de réformer pour déplaire ça ça peut
arriver
il s'agit pas non plus de réformer pour
des faits il s'agit de réformer la
france pour que notre pays puisse être
plus productif puisse continuer à tenir
son rang et accroître son influence dans
le monde
ces réformes elle requiert de la
constance dans la préparation d'abord
dans l'explication ensuite dans
l'exécution enfin car les résultats met
toujours du temps avant d'apparaître et
c'est précisément là que le hiatus
secret parce que nos concitoyens n'ont
plus de temps n'ont pas de temps pour
eux l'urgence c'est tous les jours
comment comprendre que nous ayons nous
nos procédures nos délais et si je puis
dire nos précautions comment comprendre
que nous vivons à l'échelle d'un mandat
que ce soit un quinquennat où que ce
soit un mandat plus long pour les élus
des collectivités
quand les français ont une seule
actualité c'est celle du jour nous
devons donner de la profondeur aux
réformes que nous engageons ne pas nous
laisser emporter par
immédiateté et donner un sens à ce que
nous faisons alors même que tout est
fait pour ramener le récit à un
quotidien la france a démontré aussi
dans ces derniers jours qu'elle voulait
aller dans une direction connaître un
sens un sens ce n'est pas simplement un
cap c'est un contenu de savoir ce qui
fait que notre pays est ce qu'il est et
regardé comme un pays qui n'est pas
comme les autres pourquoi autant de
chefs d'état de gouvernement sont venus
le 11 janvier pas simplement parce
qu'ils étaient eux aussi
effrayé par ce qui s'était produit mais
parce que c'était la france qui était
touchée et le fait qu'il y ait des
millions de nos concitoyens avec des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement de
sensibilité bien différente de continent
bien différents mais qui étaient là
c'est le signe c'est la confirmation
pour beaucoup que la france est un pays
qui a une singularité c'est parce que
nous avons cette haute idée de nous
mêmes que nous pouvons être confiants
dans notre avenir
c'est quand le pays doute que le pays
s'inquiète qu'il rompt avec son destin
est la preuve le premier devoir qui doit
être le nôtre quel que soit notre niveau
de responsabilité quelles que soient nos
oppositions qui peuvent être légitimes
c'est de faire en sorte que le pays soit
uni sur l'essentiel
alors nous devons aussi
réformer notre organisation
l'organisation territoriale
aujourd'hui nous sommes en cours de le
faire déjà des régions moins nombreuses
ont été dessinés leurs compétences
seront renforcées en matière économique
l'aménagement du territoire les
départements qui ont été finalement
maintenu pour un temps seront recentrées
sur leurs missions de solidarité
les intercommunalités seront capables de
garantir avec un niveau de population
qui peut varier selon les territoires de
garantie l'accès aux services publics
pour que les communes de puisse agir
seuls cantons n'en n'ont plus les moyens
pour l'état il y aura des conséquences
dans la représentation qui sera la
sienne sur les territoires pour les
collectivités il y aura forcément de
nouvelles méthodes nouvelles formes
d'action sur le territoire et pour la
démocratie il y aura une action publique
plus lisible mais il doit y avoir aussi
une participation aux décisions plus
simple
l'état doit concentrer son action sur
les fonctions régaliennes elles sont
essentielles
mais également sur les missions de
cohésion sociale de lutte contre les
inégalités et de projection dans le long
terme l'état doit être plus des
concentrés plus proche plus rapide plus
confiants aussi dans ses relations avec
les acteurs de la société
ce qui suppose aussi que l'état gère
mieux ses ressources humaines
l'état a tendance à faire leçon à tous
et notamment aux entreprises l'est
pourtant il y a encore beaucoup à faire
à l'intérieur de l'état il ya eu
heureusement des négociations qui se
sont tenues en 2013 avec un accord
unanime sur l'égalité professionnelle
femmes hommes en 2015 un accord-cadre
sur la qualité de la vie au travail qui
a été négociée doit être rapidement
validé il prévoira un droit d'expression
directe des agents sur l'organisation du
travail
des règles de bon usage du télétravail
des mesures de conciliation entre vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle et
des dispositions de prévention des
risques psychosociaux je souhaite qu'il
y ait aussi une vraie négociation
sur l'avenir de la fonction publique la
ministre en est chargé il ne s'agit pas
de fragiliser de statut mais de
moderniser nos textes pour ouvrir les
carrières et encourager une véritable
mobilité entre les trois fonctions
publiques qui ne peuvent pas être des
organes séparer les uns des autres
redonner confiance dans l'avenir c'est
aussi pour l'administration
allait pleinement vers la révolution
numérique
l'administration française
que l'on brocarde souvent pour ses
traditions pour son organisation a
néanmoins considérablement développé
l'usagé du numérique
ainsi un tiers des contribuables
déclarent déjà leurs revenus en ligne et
il ya eu beaucoup de procédures qui ont
maintenant été dématérialisée l'onu a
classé la france première en europe
quatrième dans le monde pour les
services numériques
ce classement d'une certaine façon nous
oblige à aller plus loin donc en 2015
verra deux chantiers majeurs s'ouvrir
d'abord 100% des démarches qui ne
nécessite pas la présence obligatoire à
un guichet vont être élaborés en ligne
ensuite il y aura un identifiant unique
qui permettra à chaque citoyen de
n'avoir plus à ne donner qu'une seule
fois à une seule administration
et une fois que ces données auront été
ainsi livré les autres administrations
pourront utiliser directement ces
informations sur un compte personnel
sécurisé sans que l'intéressé n'est à
tout en renseignant et une seconde fois
et j'espère avec le soutien de la cnil
nous pourrons donc aller plus loin en
mobilisant des raisons comme celui de la
poste parce que en définitive nous avons
un réseau formidable avec la poste qui
nous permettra d'installer du numérique
dans beaucoup de domaines qui
simplifieront la vie quotidienne des
français je pense à la justice à
l'éducation à l'accès aux droits sociaux
parce que justement la lourdeur
l'opacité la complexité empêche les plus
fragiles de pouvoir accéder à leurs
droits
le numérique peut aussi être un moyen
d'améliorer la qualité du débat public
de revivifier la démocratie et notamment
en ouvrant largement les données
publiques parce que c'est devenu un
nouveau bien public et donc ce capital
c'est les données publiques servira à
inventer de nouveaux services et de
mieux répondre à des besoins sociaux
lors de la conférence environnementale
j'ai annoncé la création d'une base
public rassemblant toutes les études
d'impact tous les dossiers toutes les
évaluations de projets et
d'investissements publics de notre pays
de manière à ce que le citoyen puisse
accéder à toutes ces informations pour
les utiliser autant qu'il sera possible
dans le débat public
nous devons aussi consulter plus
directement les citoyens à chaque fois
que c'est nécessaire et avoir une
participation au débat public qui soit
d'une autre qualité
l'exemple de sivens la montre et lorsque
le dialogue est dans l'impasse c'est la
violence qui risque de prendre le dessus
et qui peut nous entraîner jusqu'au
drame
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
souhaité que soit revu nos procédures de
décision publique et favoriser la
participation voire l'expression directe
des citoyens parce que dans certaines
situations
le vote est nécessaire le droit
l'autorisent cette opportunité doit être
saisie pour conclure un certain nombre
de débats
nous devons également introduire de
nouveaux outils de démocratie
participative c'est déjà le cas dans la
politique de la ville avec des conseils
citoyens et les maisons de projets mais
il doit y avoir d'autres procédures
d'autres méthodes sur de grands sujets
les jurys citoyens les états généraux
les conférences de consensus
doivent nous permettre sur des sujets
importants aboutir à une forme de
conclusion qui peu ou qui ne peut pas
engager ensuite les acteurs mais c'est
ainsi que nous avons procédé pour la
réforme pénale où le débat sur la fin de
vie et ses méthodes devons être
davantage utilisé
la france accueillera je ne vous
apprends rien la 21e conférence des
parties sur le changement climatique
la coop 21 c'est un enjeu tout à fait
décisif et nous devons nous y préparer
préparer c'est le rôle des diplomates
dans les négociations qui sont en cours
mais nous préparer aussi dans notre pays
pour être une référence pour être un
exemple la commission nationale du débat
public sera donc chargé de préparer ce
rendez-vous avec une idée simple dans
100 pays du monde sans citoyens ou
citoyennes seront réunis pour donner
leur avis sur les grands axes de la
négociation une forme de consultation
citoyenne à l'échelle du monde je me
réjouis que le président de l'assemblée
nationale est était un des premiers à
s'associer à cette démarche et je
souhaite que le parlement puisse être
dans son ensemble partie prenante du
débat sur la conférence environnemental
et sur donc la coop 21 pour parvenir un
accord en décembre il faudra convaincre
tous les pays
et nous devrons là aussi leur montrer
que nous avons nous pays d'accueil fait
les étapes essentielles
la transition énergétique n'est pas
simplement qu'un projet de loi
aujourd'hui en débat au sénat il doit
déjà nous engager un plan pour une
administration exemplaire en matière de
transition énergétique sera présenté par
la ministre de l'écologie début février
le gouvernement aura à se comparer et
dispositifs seront plus lisible pour les
fonctionnaires et pour les citoyens et
il y aura des projets ambitieux en
termes de mobilité propre de
consommation d'énergie et de traitement
de déchets dans toutes nos
administrations
le conseil économique social et
environnemental
un rôle particulier à jouer dans cette
période
puisqu'il peut rassembler toutes les
parties prenantes à l'échelle de notre
pays il peut être un lieu de dialogue un
lieu de débat un lieu de concertation et
même
rendez vous international
son renouvellement à la fin de l'année
ce qui correspondra également à la
conférence sur le climat sera l'occasion
de faire de cette assemblée
nécessaire à notre pays un lieu encore
plus représentatif de toute notre
société
là messieurs dans les circonstances que
nous vivons dans les épreuves que nous
avons traversée et face aux menaces qui
n'ont pas disparu parce qu'elles n'ont
pas disparu et que nous devons regarder
en face
nous avons plus que jamais besoin de la
république et de l'état
car vers qui les français sont-ils
tourner quand les valeurs fondamentales
ont été mises en cause
vers la république
face aux menaces terroristes
face à la haine vers qui les français se
sont-ils tournée pour les protéger vers
l'état
et l'hommage populaire dans les cortèges
du 11 janvier aux forces de l'ordre en
était le plus grand témoignage
vers qui se tourner ton lorsqu'il y à
des condamnations à faire des punitions
à prévoir
vers la justice
que demande-t-on lorsqu'il ya une crise
comme celle qui vient de se produire
qu'à c'est une crise qui touche au coeur
de notre république
plus d'encadrement plus de pédagogie
plus d'instruction c'est à dire vers
l'école et vers les enseignants
voilà ce que nous pouvons tirer comme
conclusion
la république est encore une espérance
et vous êtes ici ses représentants vous
incarnez son autorité et ses valeurs et
aujourd'hui au delà de vous et à travers
vous c'est à tous les fonctionnaires à
tous les magistrats à tous les agents
qui sont le visage de l'état et des
collectivités que je m'adresse à chaque
instant en chaque point du territoire ce
sont eux qui décident protège et duke
soigne aide réguler juge et contrôle en
un mot ils servent l'intérêt général je
m'adresse aussi à tous les élus qui font
face à eux aussi chaque jour à des
difficultés sans nom je ne parle pas
simplement des contraintes financières
je parle aussi de l'état de notre
société des attentes considérables qui
sont portées
des impatiences des inquiétudes des
peurs
s'il n'y avait pas d'élu dans la
république capable d'être là comme ils
l'ont été aussi dans ces derniers jours
il n'y aurait pas de république ainsi
attendues ainsi espérer en amour vous
servez tous l'intérêt général c'est un
choix de devoir qui vous honore et qui
vous place mesdames et messieurs en
première ligne dans les combats que nous
avons à mener ensemble
vive la république et vive la france